monsieur benedetti merci à d'être en
direct avec moi alors hier emmanuel
macron confirmé et qu'il n'y aura pas de
déconfinement par avion c'était pourtant
une des pistes à étudier au début oui
mais on voit bien que de toute façon
l'exécutif essaye de mettre en place une
stratégie de déconfinement mais que le
déconfinement sera certainement encore
plus difficile que le confinement de là
mais était ce à quoi nous assistons
depuis
finalement le début de cette crise c'est
à une communication qui illustre d'une
certaine manière les hésitations et
voire parfois les imprévoyance de
l'action publique
une communication qui essaye de donner
du sens à son action mais vous savez
quand l'action apparaît désordonnée ou
qu'elle apparaît insuffisante
il est très difficile pour une
communication de pouvoir rendre lisible
l'action d'un émetteur quels qu'ils
soient et à fortiori d'un exécutif alors
le 11 mai en date on nous annonce
finalement c'est pas forcément les
déconfinement totalement tout cas
seulement le début du déconfinement oui
alors on voit bien que c'est plutôt une
journée grise qui est en train d'essayer
des stores et l'exécutif contre 1 des
confinement qui manifestement ne
s'accomplira que de manière très
conditionnel et une sortie qui elle
lèverait s'empare pour tout de suite
pour l'ensemble de la société
il ya plusieurs questions qui se posent
in fine et la première question c'est la
question des moyens pour que le
dégonflement se fasse disons de manière
sereine il faut que nous puissions
disposer de moyens qui permettent de
lutter contre l'épidémie et les moyens
il y en a de deux ordres qui sont
absolument essentielles est récurrent
depuis le début de cette épidémie c'est
les masques et des tests
le deuxième aspect qui est important et
qui vrai sens explique que l'exécutif
aujourd'hui veuille absolument tenir
cette date du respect c'est que il y a
deux paramètres qui sont tout à fait
fondamentaux le premier paramètre c'est
le paramètre économique parce que il
faut
redémarrer la machine économique et que
par exemple le retour des enfants à
l'école est aussi nié vous fait qu'il
faut libérer des parents pour que les
parents puissent retourner à leur compte
de travail et le deuxième paramètre
c'est qu'on voit qu'il ya d'autres pays
voisins qui eux ont déjà entamé une
stratégie de déconfinement avancé donc
il faut aussi montrer que la france ce
n'est pas trop en retard par rapport à
ses grands voisins européens européen
l'italienne vad est confiné sa
population partir du 3 mai à veut rendre
le port du masque obligatoire limiter
l'affluence dans les transports et puis
des pistes est massivement
est ce que en tout cas ce sont des
contours de déconfinement qui vont
paraissent logiques à l'écouté à écouter
quand même les plus les experts de la
question aujourd'hui le port du masque
n'est plus on débat puisque je rappelle
l'académie de médecine nationale de
médecine vient il y a cela 48 heures je
crois elle même de promouvoir et de dire
qu'il était absolument indispensable
quant à la question des tests également
c'est un des sujets qui me permet de
rendre ce des compléments beaucoup plus
opérationnel donc il faut absolument
aujourd'hui que l'on puisse disposer des
moyens qui permettent à des confinement
qui soins déconfinement qui rassure la
population et surtout et qui crée les
conditions d'un redémarrage de la
société parce qu'il faut quand même
rappeler que le confinement c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas naturel à
une société une société elle est là pour
fonctionner et pour vivre à l'extérieur
des murs de son propre domicile de ses
propos domicile merci d'avoir à peine
vous êtes rédacteur en chef de la revue
politique et parlementaire merci